- [Man] I really need the meme video
of a Jets fan talks to a Patriots fan.
- Oh yeah, I'll get that.
- Where I destroy that kid.
♫ We're unstoppable ♫
What time is it?
2:10.
2:10 p.m.
Team Gary off-site had
the, early this morning
had the people from Vayner
Productions and the creative team
and the CFO come out here,
as well, for an off-site
to get Vayner Media and
Vayner Productions aligned
on how we produce and all that stuff,
super excited about that.
Now, here with 20 or so homies.
(hip hop music)
Huge, huge miss by Babin.
To start off, he was
supposed to be filming
the last four hours of this.
We went around and kinda got
acquainted with each other,
with updates.
Started working on my kind
of text, CRM infrastructure.
Did a lot of awesome
stuff, lost now in history
'cause when I yelled at Babin,
"Hey Babin, weren't you supposed
to be filming all this?"
His amazing reply was, "Oh, yeah."
That's where were at right now.
Now we're talking about
the Gary Vee search engine.
If you go garyvaynerchuk.com,
under Ask Gary Vee,
there's a search engine.
We're developing a 2.0 version on that.
Gotta work with Castner,
Andy, the rest of the team.
So, just some team bonding.
Some strategies around creative utility
and all the projects I'm working on,
whether it's the K-Swiss, the book,
the wine club, hip hop collaborations,
just really focusing.
This new search engine that you guys have,
if you wanna pull it up Andy.
Supposedly this is better
than what we had, right?
- Better.
- Good.
- [Man] Because it's all content,
and it plays from the moment.
- [Man] It's all YouTube.
- [Gary] Good.
So put in Snapchat.
Yeah, this is fuckin' awesome.
- It's using Daily Vee too, right?
- Yeah, so hit, so hit key notes,
hit key notes just for a second.
- Type in Instagram, it should
be a Daily Vee that pulls up
versus an Ask Gary Vee video.
- [Gary] Hold on.
But you can get by Daily Vee anyways.
- [Man] No, I'm saying all.
- [Man] Hit all.
- [Man] Hit all, and then
I wanna see what comes up.
- It's super random, but who cares?
That's super easy.
We would go by most recent.
- [Man] We do have to get
Facebook content on there too.
- I think it's very important.
- We're debating the Ask Gary Vee,
the Gary Vee actual search
engine transcribing.
As some of you guys know,
on my website Ask Gary Vee,
tab on my website, you can search any word
and get the information.
We know this is valuable.
We've got content on the podcast,
we've got content on the YouTube channel.
We're moving to Ask Gary
Vee on Facebook only.
So, we're just debating it.
And then debating if it's
even worth it right now.
- Internally, I think it's 100% worth it.
- Kendall or Iris or somebody, Justin,
can I get the, I really
need the meme video
of a Jets fan talks to a Patriots fan.
- Oh yeah, I'll get that for you.
- Where I destroy that kid.
So, I get to Boise.
I meet this kid.
- Josh, it was nice meeting
you in the airport, man.
- Later at the conference,
he asks this question
and he asks me, and at the
end he tries to razz me,
he's like--
- [Josh] If Tom Brady makes it
to the Super Bowl this year,
will you go to the Super
Bowl with me on me?
- No.
I have not watched the
Patriots play a down
of a Super Bowl game in
the last four Super Bowls
that they've played in, because I refuse.
Everybody's like the greatest
comeback in a Super Bowl.
I'm good.
I have no idea what the fuck
you guys are talking about,
I didn't see shit.
(laughter)
- [Josh] You like winners,
and I'd like to invite you to be a winner.
- Why don't we hang out and I'll come
and show you what real winners,
you know, you'll get to see
real winners play, right?
You're a Jets fan, I'm a Patriots fan,
I'm gonna show you how real winning looks
or something, I go--
- No, no, no, no, Josh.
Josh, you're confused, my friend.
I'm a winner.
You root for winners, dick.
(laughter)
Be careful.
- Maybe we should title it When Jets Fans
Actually Beat Patriot Fans, or something.
We gotta figure out the right title.
I want Super Phone.
Like, if we leave here in a couple hours
and nothing was accomplished,
I'm gonna kill somebody.
Like Super Phone should be done.
I actually do engagement.
Like, I'm just hitting up these people.
Is this a bot?
Watch this.
Camera.
Okay.
Reverse.
Video.
Okay.
- [Man] 10 episodes.
- Three days in New York.
- If my name is Bot now, it is.
(laughter)
I mean, that guy is gonna shit in his taxi
getting that video.
Ready?
- Go.
- Hey guys, it's Gary Vaynerchuk.
Dressed down and excited for
the first Monthly Wine Club of October.
First of all, I want to start with
thanking everybody for subscribing
to the Monthly Wine Club.
My big goal is to create the most epic,
the coolest, the best
wine club in the world.
And I hope you enjoyed our
first interaction together.
If you want to join my Monthly Wine Club,
go to winelibrary.com
and search Gary V-E-E.
YouTube, right now I'm recording
for the Alexa skill for Wine Library,
which is coming out soon.
So, just say "start tasting" to Alexa,
and let's rock and roll.
Awesome, what I want to do
is I don't want the back,
I want them to like be floating.
I don't want the back.
- Yeah, that's fine.
- Got it, got it.
These are just kinda all over it now.
- Perfect.
- Sweet.
- And then you'll show
me a three, two, and one?
- Yep.
- What's the update?
- So, we're trying to get a hotspot,
so we can go on Girlpower
and update all the--
- Do we have any actions?
Did you get good audio or was it--
- The audio's like pretty not--
- You're gonna transcribe it, right?
- Yeah.
- Okay.
Okay, I love it.
So, I like everything.
You can keep it from that part.
Like, I like where,
all you have to do is,
when you made that thing,
I want you to take over the whole screen,
put it in green, just green lettering,
and just like really impact,
like good design in it,
like the design in that,
and just put like, "this
is where it turns."
- Mm-hmm.
(audio playing on phone)
- Episode 292 just dropped.
Getting in the comments.
(audio playing on phone)
Lander Hendrickx likes the editing.
That's for you, Babin.
Just trying to build your self esteem up.
(laughter)
Um, see what else is happening.
You like that one, Seth?
Why was that so funny?
I thought that was subtle.
(laughter)
Hey, you know what, I
might have all of you guys
travel with me now.
I like the laugh track.
This is the theme.
CWorldIntergalactic mentions,
and he's one of four people,
she or he is one of four people,
the die on your own sword part,
which I obviously was the focus of this,
is so imperative.
I'm glad to see a lot of people
understand where I'm coming from in that.
Too many people conforming
and are gonna end up losing.
And that's like a double loss.
You're just better off
holding your, your conviction,
and if you lose, at
least you only lost once.
A lot of people don't realize
they're on a path of oh and two.
And if I'm gonna lose, I'd
rather be one and one, right?
(audio playing on phone)
Paulinejustliving says,
"the title nailed it,
"the description nailed it."
Good job, copy team.
Comic Devour, amazing
observation in the workout video.
Yes, that is correct.
That is a bald bull.
Mike Tyson's punch-out t-shirt.
Good job.
(audio playing on phone)
I like you characters in the comments.
You're just giving me feedback and love.
I love that.
Michael Ruscito says, "D-rock
did you edit this one?
"Very, very good edit job."
The answer to that is, he sure didn't.
I love that people,
let's just keep it on
his face the whole time.
- Alright.
- [Gary] Seth's enjoying it.
Seth, you think everything's funny today.
- Everything's funny.
- Handles everywhere.
- Handles on handles.
- Babin, Babin, Babin.
- Guys, it's Gary Vaynerchuk.
You are seeing this video,
because I am announcing
the Digital Uncorked series
by Vayner Media.
- Josh, what are you asking?
I'll give you the answer.
I'm a winner.
You root for winners, dick.
(laughter on phone)
- Having these off-sites is important.
You gotta break the
patterns, break the rhythms.
Get everybody aligned.
Get everybody aligned on the same mission,
what are we doing here.
I feel good about today so far.
Good day.
I feel like we're wrapping up soon.
You know, some people
performed better than others.
We know who they are.
(smooth music)